five I think it's ingrained in us it's
just how you were raised and what
happened to you in your life well I I
don't like Lord of the Flies situation
of us would you eat first yeah which one
about which one I'm not a gay guy so I'm
eating you first penis I'm not touching
you
yeah what's wrong what I eat first
mallanna I do George first because I
like my own taste
[Laughter]
yeah I would eat him first because he's
always high he wouldn't even know what's
going on yeah okay army women I would
eat you first why you've been through a
lot
he has Rhino hide foreskin it's
impenetrable right we would hide in a
tree for two weeks with a banana right
we're survivors I don't know why the
tall gene is dominant when shorter
people live longer yeah yeah it doesn't
make sense like why did what is that why
does that happen
women like it so people stretch
themselves out cuz chicks like tall
dudes chicks do like you know like
ominous yeah except you yeah personality
yeah because he's all paws because you
know what he gives off he gives off like
a life he gives off like a vitality that
I think what you see
ya know it gives off this vitality this
life force for you I think
subconsciously in your head are saying
you know you find him attractive and you
love all these things about vitality
positive energy where you say he would
give me a deal he's a fun [ __ ] now yeah
he's jumping around the room he flies
down like watching Tiger Hidden Dragon
on the tree I think it goes deeper than
that I think present Filipino and
colonial mentality of always having like
seeing like praising the coat the
colonists and I think deep down inside I
think that you're an oppressor and a
colonizer and somehow gets my [ __ ] wet
Asians over an hour all right yeah so
here's what we do at the end okay